2023 has been a year of surprises what
if I tell you that 2024 has more in
store for everyone it's really early but
between the currently confirmed new
anime and confirmed sequels 2024 shaping
up to be a gear to remember for today
I'll be giving you a preview of 2024 by
running down a preemptive list of the
most anticipated anime series that are
coming next year some great sequels
promising new anime and one of the most
anticipated titles to get an adaptation
incoming
[Music]
the witch and the Beast will be the
first entry
[Music]
we have here one of the shows looking to
set the tone for the year set to air in
Winter 2024 the witch and the Beast is
already looking to be one of the more
artistic titles the year has prepared
for us putting us once again in a
European setting made familiar To Us by
the likes of Undead murder Foss or
vanitas we can easily infer what to
expect in the witch and the Beast shows
in these kinds of settings often come
with a flare for the dramatic and the
Mysterious and this show is no exception
for this show we get introduced to First
Class Mage ashaf and the temperamental
Guido a pair who deal with problems of
the magical variant the latter has been
struck with a Witch's Curse and this is
the story of her quest for Revenge but
it won't come easy as witches have
become powerful beings looming ominously
over Society the witch and the Beast is
a thriller with no shortage of mysteries
and complex character motivations it's
overall a pretty good show to pick up as
the year starts as it provides a lot of
engaging elements that both veteran and
new anime fans can take a liking too
thank you
[Music]
up next will be the second season of
Marshall
college
now that didn't take long did it it just
seemed like months ago but everyone's
favorite comically overpowered hero is
back to Grace our screens it looks like
more of those second calls disguised as
a second season but does it matter
Marshall is coming back and it's going
to be as wild as ever Marshall has
always been a ton of fun since its first
season and a lot of fans couldn't get
enough of what seems to be one punch
man's spiritual successor with the
second season expect more of the same
from the show and what made it such an
entertaining watch Marshall is a show
that has a simple plot by all means but
the comedy just takes the series to new
heights for a show that seems to be
nothing but dumb fun it's got some
genuinely epic battles and it could be
your show to watch if you're up for some
light-hearted excitement
soccer
team
here's a wholesome title in a sign of
affection
[Music]
foreign
if you need some Shoujo romance to
change things up a bit then you have it
here with a sign of affection due to
being hearing impaired Yuki pretty much
grew up in her own little world her only
interaction coming from her best friend
rid just when it seemed that she'd be
resigned to a life of monotony she runs
into itsuomi rin's friend who happens to
take an interest in Yuki being
understanding of her impairment thus a
new chapter in Yuki's life opens with a
girl finding a growing fondness in this
new light to her world now with that
synopsis I'm positive that you know how
the story is going to go expect an
emotional ride despite this a sign of
affection remains rather light-hearted
instead of melodramatic it's sweet
romantic and most importantly it's
hopeful and uplifting definitely a show
to watch out for in 2024
[Music]
makes its return in 2024.
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
back for another run after what seemed
like a very long silence on the anime
side of things things were announced in
waves back in 2022 after the spin-off
that recently concluded it's finally
time for the big thing the next season
to the main story and it's coming in
2024 by this point konosuba has arguably
become a gold standard for isakai comedy
it's always been a popular show that's
very unrestrained in what it does
whether it be the lewd and degenerate
jokes the exaggerated reaction faces and
the in your face nature of the comedy
that has given it a signature charm
that's gone Advanced from anime fans
everywhere and it's coming back with a
whole array of new jokes and Insanity
next year fans have been waiting for
this for years now and it's time for
them to have the time of their lives
once again
Spice and Wolf is up next for the Remake
treatment
foreign
what a surprising remake Spice and Wolf
has been one of the enduring success
stories from Dengue bunco and this title
getting a remake in 2024 is a pleasant
surprise I have a lot of fond memories
of the show as it was a beautiful
fantasy romance adventure with a touch
of medieval economics the anime has been
one of the better adapted light novels
out there but I guess we can't have too
much Holo so if you weren't around back
in the late 2000s Spice and Wolf tells
the story of the traveling Merchant
Lawrence looking to open up his own shop
he runs into the wolf deity of Legend
the Harvest goddess Holo finding a
suitable partner in Holo due to her
abilities Lawrence travels the
countryside of this new partner the two
of them carrying their own aspirations
as they explore and learn more about the
colorful world around them I do think
this is an attempt to revive the
franchise as it's been almost two
decades already would be nice to see
some new faces in the fan base if you're
curious to know what the height from the
older anime is all about don't hesitate
to take the jump and watch this show
when it airs next year
[Music]
foreign
2024's looking good and we've got a lot
more amazing anime ahead before we get
to them go hit that like button as it's
going to help this video do better and
help the channel grow done all right
let's get back to the show next up is
classroom of the elite season three
from a series that people have been
wanting a sequel to into two sequels in
quick succession classroom of the elite
has been having a pretty nice run as of
late then again with the success of the
novels I do think this third season
shouldn't be seen as unexpected when it
was announced alongside the second
season back then and it's always welcome
to see more of everyone's favorite big
brain protagonist back in Action
classroom of the elite has often been
cited as a series that's better read
than watched due to the amount of
dialogue and how much it relies on
getting to know the context and the
inner workings of the characters still
that doesn't mean that the anime won't
be enjoyable the second season upped the
stakes and created a more streamlined
narrative making it a far more enjoyable
watch compared to the first one with the
anime team on a roll we can expect
season 3 to follow the same pattern they
better do with the next season having
more cool mental battles in store
oh
sorry
oshinoko makes his return for a second
season in 2024.
[Music]
the biggest anime hits of 2023 it would
be a shocker if a sequel was never
announced especially with the
Cliffhanger at the end of the first
season thankfully our weight won't have
to be too long and the Tokyo blade Arc
will Grace our screens next year things
are about to come to a head with what
some consider to be one of oshinoko's
best arcs love triangles personal demons
and a murder mystery still looming in
the background things are looking real
good for oshinoko and after some great
arcs for the first season that's saying
something oshinoko has been a fan
favorite and for good reason too I'm
sure you might be pleased to see these
characters who've captured our hearts
make a comeback and the show will
continue to dazzle with its heartfelt
stories and commentaries on the
entertainment industry it's got
everything you'd want for an anime in
this genre and it's only getting better
how about a new animator spice things up
a bit gaiju number eight is up next
foreign
with anime series getting Greenly it
seems not so long after getting chainsaw
man we have gaiju number eight ready to
make its mark on the anime world you can
see where this is going now can't you
guide you number eight is the story of
Kafka who's long resigned to being a
sweeper which is exactly what it says
people who dispose of guide you remains
after the action's done he long dreamed
of being on the front lines and taking
on the grotesque monsters himself for
such a dream felt like an insanely Long
Reach thankfully or not the encounters
are parasite type Kaiju one that attacks
him and turns him into a monster finally
having the power to take on the monster
is one of them Kafka gives his dream of
fighting the Kaiju a shop a familiar
premise in a familiar setup guide you
number eight seems to be a show looking
to burn on the success of Chainsaw man
the story is really fun and the fight
scenes are nothing but spectacular in
manga form it's a story that's full of
hype moments that just refuses to let
you put it down my bar is not the one
handling the series in anime form around
positive production IG can also knock it
out of the park with this one if you've
been looking for more Monster mashes
that's full of high octane fight scenes
come to the right place
at number two we take a look at Blue
lock season two foreign
[Music]
true to my expectations blue law could
become one of the hottest Sports series
out there I mean how could it not be
though it's got a unique way of
approaching its story it's not every day
that you have a more cynical and darker
take on the sports story and we're in an
era now where that's what a lot of anime
viewers like it also helps that the plot
is fairly easy to follow it opens the
doors to some intricacies that will put
our characters to the test I mean don't
get me wrong this isn't exactly a sport
show that brandishes its realism in
spite of doing away with the usual
friendship tropes and Sports Anime and
the like but it does make for a very
interesting watch and season two looks
to pick up where the first season left
off we don't have much info on this one
yet but it seems poised for a late 2024
release 8 Bits done a decent job at the
series so far and if they can straighten
out some wrinkles with season one's
production then this ought to be golden
the world's watching and the
expectations are Sky High for season two
of blue locks
[Music]
to cap things off we have solo leveling
foreign
if you've been anywhere near the web
novel scene the past couple of years
you'd likely have heard of solo leveling
being one of the most popular titles on
the internet it felt like an
inevitability that it would get an anime
adaptation especially coming off the
heels of those major Korean titles
getting anime adaptations back in 2020.
originally scheduled for 2023 the anime
has since been pushed back to 2024 but I
think that just increases the
anticipation for it after all people
just couldn't get enough of this story
of super-powered humans who combat
monsters why well it's a dark Underdog
Story that's an Unapologetic power
fantasy and backed with spectacular art
in its source material its success
should come as no surprise people just
love those whole weak to strong stories
with hype moments as seen with the
popularity of things like Ari fioreta
and that's precisely why this is one of
the most anticipated anime for the year
2024. if you can't wait to see what the
buzz is all about for solar leveling
well you don't have to wait for much
longer
and that about wraps up this list do you
think that there are other shows coming
in 2024 that the anime Community can't
wait for well do tell me in the comment
section below if that's the case hope
you had a good time watching this video
thanks for your time and I'd like
nothing more but to see you again in the
next one